اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره على شاشه العربيه لتداعيات
الموقف في السودان سنتابع في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه اخر التطورات
[موسيقى]
على وقع استمرار للشبكات خارجيه جنوب
السودان تعلن موافقه مبدئيا للبرهان
وحميدتي على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا بعد
غد
ومبعوث البرهان يقول ان مجلس السياده
سيعمل على عمليه سياسيه شامله بالسودان
دون اقصاء لاي كيان
اعداد هائله من المصابين
عادات كبيره جدا
وفي التطورات الانسانيه ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا المدنيين جراءها للشبكات في
السودان الى 447 قتيلا واكثر من 2200 جريح
ومن اخبارنا الدوليه في هذه النشره ايضا
بعد شهور من التحضيرات الجيش الاوكراني
يعلن بدا الهجوم المضاد على القوات
الروسيه في بحموت
[موسيقى]
كل
المراكزله
الان نحن في رامز ظروف
[موسيقى]
نعمل فيه هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم
امكانيات اللي ما موجوده هنا
سحق بعض الادويه والمعدات
على وقع اصوات الانفجارات والاسلحه
الثقيله واختراقات هنا وهناك اعلنت خارجيه
جنوب السودان عن ان البرهان وحميدتي وافق
مبدئيا على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا في
الرابع من مايو الجاري على الارض
الاشتباكاته بين الجيش والدعم السريع
تركزت في العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها ثلاثه
فيما شن الطائرات الجيش غارات جويه على
نقاط الدعم السريع في عده مناطق اما
الاوضاع الطبيه فباتت في تفاقم مستمر حيث
خرجت عشرات المستشفيات من الخدمه فيما
باتت المخازن الطبيه فارغه في بعض
الولايات
[موسيقى]
هذا ونشر حساب
المتخصص بالخرائط الحربيه خريطه لمنطقه
المعارك في الخرطوم اليومي الثلاثاء حيث
تظهر الخريطه سيطره واضحه للجيش في اغلب
مناطق العاصمه خصوصا من جهه الشمال في وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم تظهر الخريطه حاله تجاذب
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في وقت تتوسع
سيطره قوات الدعم باتجاه جنوب العاصمه
هذا وقال السفير دفع الله الحاج علي
المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان قال انه سيتم
ترتيب عمليه سياسيه شامله بالسودان بعد
نهايه الازمه واضاف السفير ان الهدنه
الحاليه في السودان انسانيه ولا اتفاق او
مفاوضات مع الدعم السريع كما قال دفع الله
الحاج علي ان الجيش السوداني لن يقبل باي
حلول تفرض عليه كما اكد مبعوث البرهان
توجيه دعوه الى الجامعه العربيه والاتحاد
الافريقي للعب دور في ازمه السودان
اؤكد لكم انه عندما تنجلي هذه الازمه
قريبا
وتتحقق وتسيطر الشرعيه في البلاد
سيكون الامر
خلافه ما كان عليه بمعنى ان يتم
الدخول
وترتيب عمليه سياسيه واسعه شامله
لا يتم فيها اقصاء اي من الكائنات
السياسيه السودانيه الا ما سبق ان اتفق
عليه السودانيين للتمهيد
للانتقال الديمقراطي الحر
وعن وقف اطلاق النار قال السفير دفع الله
الحج مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
ان الجيش السوداني يتعاطى مع الهدنه على
اساس انها هدنه انسانيه نافيا ان يكون
هناك اي تفاوض مع قوات الدعم السريع حتى
الان
مفهومنا الان فيما يتعلق بالهدنه هي هدنه
انسانيه
ليست هنالك ليس هنالك حديث عن
اي اتفاق ولا تفاوض مباشر مع المليشيا
المتمرده نعم اقول لك نحن
سندعو
الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي
للاطلاع بدور فيما يتعلق بهذه الهدنه
والدول التي بادرت بها وهي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ونامل ان يكون للجامعه العربيه ثغلا ووزنا
وخاصه ان الاخ الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه قد عبر عن مشاعر
مؤيده للشرعيه في السودان منذ اليوم الاول
في هذا وفي محاوله لحلحله الازمه الراهنه
التقى وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري
بالقاهره مع السفير دفع الله الحاج علي
المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان وجرى خلال
اللقاء بحث الازمه السودانيه والصراع
المستمر منذ 18 يوما
وهذه صور تاتينا الان من العاصمه الخرطوم
نشاهد هناك نيران في السماء العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم من المفترض ان هناك
هدنه
مستمره ولكن بين الحين والاخر هناك
اختراقات تتم لهذه الهدنه نحن نشاهد اعمده
الدخان تتصاعد في سماء العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هناك اتصالات من قبل عدد من الدول
العربيه والاقليميه لمحاوله اتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار يستمر لمده اسبوع والمصادر
تشير الى ان هناك موافقه مبدئيه من
الجنرلين حميدتي والبرهان على هذه الهدنه
لكن لا تفاصيل حتى اللحظه حول طبيعه
التفاهمات التي تتم لبدء هذه الهدنه
المصادر تشير انها من المفترض ان تبدا بعد
ثلاثه ايام
هذه صور تاتينا وهي صور خاصه لنا وحصريه
للعربيه على
هذه الاعمده من الدخان التي تتصاعد في
سماء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ومصادر
العربيه تشير الى ان الطيران الحربي
استهدف مواقع عده للدعم السريع بمحيط مطار
الخرطوم مطار الخرطوم من المناطق الساخنه
التي ما زالت تشهد مواجهات مستمره رغم
الهدنه بين قوات الدعم السريع وما بين
الجيش السوداني ايضا محيط
القياده العامه
وما زلنا نتابع مع حضراتكم هذه الصور التي
تاتينا لتصاعد اعمده الدخان في سماء
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حيث طيران
الجيش استهدف مواقع عده للدعم السريع
بمحيط مطار الخرطوم في ارقام الضحايا ومع
استمرار المعارك في السودان ارتفع عدد
القتلى المدنيين جراء النزاع اذ اعلنت
نقابه الاطباء السودانيه عن ارتفاع حصيله
الاشتباكات في السودان الى 447 قتيلا
ونستمر في متابعه هذه التطورات ولكن ايضا
نتابع التطورات الانسانيه ينضم الينا
دكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه
اطباء السودان مرحبا بك دكتور عطيه الوضع
الانساني وفقا لتقارير الصادره منكم يزداد
صعوبه ماذا عن احوال المستشفيات وماذا
ايضا عن الضحايا حتى اللحظه
شكرا لكم في التعادل الجماهير الشعب
السوداني ومن الصحه والعافيه لكل الجرحى
والمصابين عوده الحميده لكل المفقودين
نعمل وضعي يزداد سوءا نحن نتخوف من اعلان
انهيار النظام الصحي لا زالت
نسمع عن وقف اطلاق النار ولا نراه ايضا لا
توجد ممرات امنه لا توجد معينات كافيه لدى
المستشفيات صعوبه ايصال الكوادر الطبيه
الوضع الامني على الارض غير مستقر تماما
في كل لحظه وحين نحن نسمع دوي اطلاق نار
وايضا اعمده الدخان في في اتجاهات مختلفه
هذا الذي يحدث بالتاكيد انتهى وينعكس
مباشره على ازدياد ارقام
الشهداء وايضا الجرحى الرقم مخيف جدا ونحن
لازلنا نعتقد ان هذه الارقام بسيطه
بمقارنه
بالعمليات العسكريه التي نراها الوصول الى
هذه المستشفيات محفوظ بالمخاطر لذلك نحن
نتوقع انه بعد انجلاء هذه الازمه وايضا
فتح الممرات الامنه سوف يعني نتحصل على
معلومات حقيقيه
في يعني تؤكد ما ذهبنا اليه فان هذه
الارقام ليست يعني هي انعكاس حقيقي لكل
الذي يحدث من هذه الحرب نعم لدينا اسئله
عديده دكتور ولكن اسمح لنا ان نتابع ايضا
هذه الصور الخاصه والحصريه لنا في العربيه
هناك دخان يتصاعد في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
بعد استهداف محيط المطار والقياده العامه
هناك بيان للجيش السوداني ومصادر تشير الى
ان طيران الجيش استهدف مقرات او بعض
الاماكن
قوات الدعم السريع ونحن نشاهد مع حضراتكم
هذه هذا التصاعد للدخان نتيجه استهداف
محيط القياده العامه في العاصمه الخرطوم
دكتور عطيه هل عادت الاشتباكات الى وتيره
مرتفعه ادت الى التصاعد في اعداد الضحايا
والصعوبه في الخدمات الصحيه لاننا على مدى
الايام القليله المضيق كنا قد شهدنا هدوءا
في مساله الاشتباكات هدنه الى حد ما سمحت
الطاقم الطبيه للتعامل مع الوضع في الارض
بشكل افضل هل تراجعنا وفقا لما لديك من
مؤشرات دكتور عطيه
وبالتاكيد متى ما زادت وتيره العمليات
العسكريه
المعينات الانسانيه او الشان الطبي وايضا
عدد الضحايا في ازدياد كوع يتاثر تاثر
مباشر نحن مره اخرى بشكل عنيف بوتيره
مرتفعه
تاكيد منذ يوم الامس وا
ليوم هذه الوتي في تسارع يعني يمكن كما
ذكرتي مقارنتها باعداد الضحايا والمصابين
ستجد ان الرقم في ازدياد في اليومين
الفائتين وايضا اتوقع انه اليوم سوف يزداد
هذا الرقم ولكن نحن يعني لازلنا نتخوف من
جانب اخر لم يتم تسليط الضوء عليه من
الاعلام العالمي وهو يعني نحن نعلم تماما
الان الناس كل
الاضواء العالميه هي مسلطه على الضحايا
هذه الحرب ولكن من العمليات العسكريه نعم
اقول ولكن هنالك ضحايا اخرين
ضحايا في منازلهم من ذوي الاعراض
المزمنه من الاطفال من الامراض من الحوامل
يعانون الامرين لا يستطيعوا الخروج واذا
استطاعوا لا يستطيعوا ايضا الحصول على
الادويه
هذه الشريحه مهمه جدا ويعني تحتاج الى
كثير رعايه واهتمام التشغيل المستشفيات
الطرفيه هي وحده او احدى الجوانب التي
نحاول ايضا تسليط الضوء بها على هؤلاء
الشريحه المهمه ونمكنهم من تلقي العلاج
فيها هذه المستشفيات الطرفيه بالتاكيد سوف
تكون يعني مساعد لهم في امكانيه الحصول
على على الادويه من وايضا على العنايه
الطبيه مفترض ان الادله العام للامم
المتحده قال انه سيبعث مجموعه من
المبعوتين في محاوله رصد الوضع الانساني
بكل تفاصيله النقطه التي تشير اليها
الدكتور عطيه هي نقطه مهمه ايضا المساله
ليست الحاجه الى معالجه المرضى او الجرحى
نتيجه الاشتباكات ولكن الامراض المزمنه
واصحاب الحالات الحرجه يحتاجون الى دعم هو
غائب الان نتيجه هذه الاشتباكات
نعم بالتاكيد انا اخوف
ما اخال زين
الدولي يعني سقوط النظام الصحي الذي نتخوف
منه الان نحن نحاول جاهدين
ترميم ما يمكن ترميمه واعاده تشغيل ما
يمكن تشغيله حتى نقدم خدمه ولو بسيطه
الكوادر الطبيه تعمل جاهده في توصيل
لازلنا نحن نعاني من ابسط المعينات الوقود
وايضا
الممرات الامنه هي هي يعني مطلوبات او اي
جهه دكتور يعني الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يقول انه يحاول للتعاون في هذه المساله
نحن نتحدث عن يعني تخصصات طبيه بحته وليس
وليس يعني متعاونين من الهلال الاحمر نحن
نحتاج في في الظرف ده الى الى يعني
اطباء وكوادر طبيه لها المقدره على
التعامل مع الحالات الجراحيه كل الذي
الحالات التي تصل الى المستشات هي حالات
جراحيه تستدعي تدخل جراحي
يعني كنا نتمنى ايضا هم اذا كانوا لديهم
المقدره في جمع الجثث من الشوارع من
الشوارع والمستشفيات لانه هذه سوف تنتهي
بكارثه بيئيه هي الاخرى مهم جدا ان نشير
الى نقطه وهي البيانات المضلله والتي
تتحدث عن ان الوضع الانساني والطبي في
السودان في في
يعني في وضع جيد جدا للاسف هذه المعلومات
مغلوطه جدا ومعلومات سوف تهدد يعني مصير
عدد من المرضى الذين يخدعوا تنطلع عليهم
هذه الخدعه بان كل المستشفيات تعمل
ببطاقتها القصوى وعندما يذهبوا لا يجدوا
ان هنالك خدمه نحن نحاول ان ننشر معلومات
حقيقيه عبر بيانات رسميه في هذه
المستشفيات يمكن توجد الخدمه المحدده نعم
اشكرك دكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير
نقابه الاطباء في السودان وما زلنا مع هذه
الصور الحصريه للعربيه من تصاعد لاعمده
الدخان في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم وتحديدا
في محيط القياده العامه والمطار نتيجه بعض
المصادر التي اشارت الى ان الجيش قام بقصف
بعض المواقع بالطيران الحربي لقوات الدعم
السريعه
وفي اطار المطالبات السودانيه المدنيه
بالتفاوض دعا ياسر عرمان الناطق الرسمي
باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان دعا
الى مظاهرات واسعه في المناطق غير
المتاثره بالصراع للدفع نحو التفاوض ووقف
الحرب اكد عرمان ان القرى والمدن التي لا
تشملها الحرب عليها ان تخرج بشكل واسع
للدفع للتفاوض ووقف الحرب في البلاد مؤكدا
ان التفاوض سيقود البلاد الى القضايا التي
طرحت للمعالجه في الاتفاق الاطري قائلا
انه لابد من قوات مسلحه مهنيه واحده وحكم
مدني في السودان
بدوره ايضا اقترح رئيس الوزراء السوداني
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لتوفير الاساس
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
الاتفاق على انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه
اقترح حمدوك ايضا اشراك المدنيين
السودانيين في مفاوضات شامله واستئناف
العمليه السياسيه مؤكدا ان استمرار الحرب
في السودان وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع قد يضر
العالم باسره
وقالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها انها
اسقطت طائره من طراز ميج تابعه للجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم وذكرت قوات الدعم
السريع انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها الجيش
السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق سكنيه
بالخرطوم
عضو مجلس السياده السوداني الفريق اول
ياسر العطا قال للعربيه ان اي وساطه
للتفاوض مع الدعم السريع غير ناجحه وان
الجيش يريد اخضاعه لسلطه الدوله موجها
شكره للسعوديه ومصر ودوله جنوب السودان
على جهودهم
انا اشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه والجمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
والجمهوريه الجنوب السودان
ومنظمه الايجارات على جهدهم في ذلك الامر
لكن لكن تاكد تمام اخي الكريم ان الوضع
الان هو وضع عمليات البحث حتى ان ارسل
من الممثلين فلم تنجح اي وساطه لان الجهد
فقط لاخباء هذا التمرد لسلطه الدوله
ومن مدينه بورسودان ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نزار البقداوي مرحبا بك نزار
مازلنا نتابع معك وكما بدات الازمه منذ
البدايه حاله اللجوء من مدينه بورسودان
ضعنا في الارقام وتطورات اليوم
نزار هل تسمعني سؤال جيدا ولكن الحديث نعم
الحديث عن مسار هذه العمليات عمليات
الاجلاء المتواصله من مدينه بورسودان الى
عدد من دول المنطقه ودول الاقليم من خلفه
كما تتابعون الان هذا هو ميناء بورسودان
هذا هو الميناء الرئيس وهذا هو المنفذ
البحري الوحيد الان لرعايه الدول الاجنبيه
ولممثلي البعثات ولموظفي الامم المتحده في
طريق اجلائهم من السودان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى عدد من الدول عبر
هذا المنفذ الرئيس الحديث الان ونحن نتحدث
عن اليوم الحادي عشر لعمليات الاجلاء بعد
مرور 18 يوما على الاشتباكات والمواجهات
المسلحه في الخرطوم وعدد من المدن اكثر من
25 رحله بحريه تمت في هذا الميناء ميناء
بورسودان
واكثر من سبعين رحله قويه تمت هنا في مطار
بورسودان الدولي بواقع ست الى ثمان رحلات
في اليوم نقلت عشرات او نقلت المئات
والالاف من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه وممثلي
البعثات الدبلوماسيه نتوقع بعد ثلاث ساعات
من الان ان تصل ايضا سفينه سعوديه ستقل
ايضا عدد من رعايا الدول الاجنبيه الذين
ما زالوا هنا في مدينه بورسودان بشرق
السودان نضيف ايضا في المعطيات بان حكومه
ولايه البحر الاحمر اعلنت اليوم عن حاله
الطوارئ وذلك في اطار التعامل والتماشي مع
الضرورات هذه المرحله التي تمر بها البلاد
وتمر بها ولايه البحر الاحمر التي تتجه
اليها الانظار باعتبار انها احد المنافذ
البحريه
والجويه لعبور مئات والاف الطالبين
لمغادره السودان جراء الاح داث التي
تشهدها البلاد
ايضا من السودانيين
هنالك عدد من اصحاب الاقامات واصحاب
الزيارات هنا في مدينه بورسودان وصلوا
خلال الايام الماضيه الى مدينه بورسودان
لاستكمال الاجراءات مغادرتهم للسودان
هنالك عدد من المقيمين في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في دول الخليج في عدد من الدول
شارفت اقاماتهم على الانتهاء هنالك طلاب
لهم ظروف تتعلق بالمعاهد العليا والجامعات
هم الان في حاجه ماسه لمغادره البلاد
هنالك ايضا سودانيون اكملوا عطله عيد
الفطر المبارك وفي طريقهم الان الى خارج
السودان ايضا تعثرت السبل في سبيل
مغادرتهم وسفرهم نسبه لان الاولويه الان
لكل البواخر توقف الطيران الجوي المدني
توقفت البواخر المدنيه التي تنقل
المواطنين من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى ميناء سواكن هنا في شرق السودان هذه
العثرات بظلال سلبيه على كثير من
السودانيين الراغبين في مغادره السودان في
ظل هذه الظروف لكن العدد الاكبر هم هو
يتعلق بطالبي مغادره السودان من اكثر من
65 جنسيه غادروا خلال الايام الماضيه مطار
بورسودان وبناء بورسودان في طريقهم لخارج
البلاد في اطار عمليه هي الكبرى لاجلاء
رعايه دول الاجنبيه من السودان نعم زميلي
نزار البقلاويه مراسل العربيه
محدثا لنا الارقام الخاصه بعمليات التي
تتم من مدينه بورسودان وهذه صور مباشره
خاصه للعربيه من ميناء بورسودان وايضا في
الجانب الاخر من الصوره هذه صور خاصه لنا
ايضا من الخرطوم قلب العاصمه السودانيه
حيث
اصعد تصاعد واضح للسنه واعمده الدخان
نتيجه قصف لمحيط المطار والقياده العامه
تجدد الاشتباكات مره اخرى طيران حربي يقوم
بقصف مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع وفقا لبعض
المصادر العسكريه التي قالت للعربيه ان
قوات الجيش قامت بقصف لمواقع للدعم السريع
هناك محاولات تتم الان للدفع بهدنه طويله
الامد وقف دائم لاطلاق النار لمده سبعه
ايام وزير خارجيه السودان
جنوب كان يقول ان هناك اتصالات ما بين
حماتي والبرهان وانهما وافق بالفعل على
ارسال مندوبين لهم وممثلين لهم لبدء
المفاوضات مكان التفاوض لم يتم تحديده بعد
تاريخ هذا التفاوض او هذه المفاوضات التي
ستجمع الجانبان لم يتم تحديدها بعد ولكن
ما هو مطروح الان هو محاوله طرح مبادرات
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار اولا لتداعيات
الانسانيه الخطيره للشبكات في السودان حتى
يتم فتح ممرات انسانيه يمكن من خلالها
دخول منظمات المجتمع المدني والمساعدات
الانسانيه لدعم الوضع الانساني الصعب وحتى
تجرى اتصالات تقوم بها كل من السعوديه
ومصر وحكومه جنوب السودان لعقد لقاء بين
ممثلي الطرفين
وفي بيان له اتهم قوات او اتهمت قوات
الدعم السريع الجيش بالتسبب في مقتل وجرح
العشرات من المواطنين بعد قصف مستشفى شرق
النيل بالطيران الحربي واوضحت قوات الدعم
السريع عبر حسابها على تويتر ان القصف
بالطيران شملان مستشفى شرق النيل الى جانب
قصف عدد من المصانع بالمنطقه الصناعيه
بحري وعدد من المنشات المدنيه والطبيه
والعسكريه
وايضا كانت هناك محاولات لمواجهه حاله
الانفلات المستمره جراء الاشتباكات الشرطه
السودانيه اعلنت انها قامت بالدفع
بتعزيزات امنيه لتامين الاسواق والمحلات
التجاريه والاحياء الشرطه السودانيه اشارت
ايضا الى قيمها بحملات خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه في عدد من مناطق جنوب
الخرطوم بمشاركه وتنسيق امني مشترك مع
القوات المسلحه
قالت ايضا المتحدثه باسم مكتب المفوض
السامي للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
انها اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ عبروا من
السودان الى الدول المجاوره هربا من
الصراع بينما نزح مئات الالاف بسبب العنف
داخل البلاد
هم من بين اولئك الذين فروا من السودان
الى البلدان المجاوره ويشمل هذا الرقم
ايضا اللاجئين في جنوب السودان المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
حددت الى جانب الحكومات والشركاء رقم
تخطيط اولي لاكثر من 800
وعائد قد يفررون من السودان الى البلدان
المجاوره
هذا وقلم متحدث باسم المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره بول دايمون ان عدد النازحين ارتفع
بوتيره سريعه في الاسبوعين الماضيين بسبب
القتال المتواصل بين المكونين العسكريين
نزح ما لا يقل عن
334 الف شخص داخليا نتيجه الصراع الحاصل
وفقا لتقرير شبكه قياس تتبع النزوح
التابعه للمنظمه الدوليه للهجره ارتفع عدد
النازحين خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين نتيجه
تواصل الصراع في السودان جميع حالات
النزوح مرتبطه بالظروف الصعبه والازمات
التي زادت منذ عام 2022
وفي متابعتنا لتطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن ان 39 مستشفى خرجت عن
الخدمه منذ بدء للشبكات مؤكدا العربيه ان
قوات الدعم السريع حولت بعض المستشفيات
لثقنات عسكريه عبد الرحمن دعا الى فتح
ممرات انسانيه لاغاثه الضحايا مسلسلات
التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ صباح يوم 15
وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه المستشفيات
هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى تاريخ اليوم
مناطق غير امنه هي مستشفيات التي متاخمه
لمناطق الاشتباك شارع القصر وشارع
المطار والقياده والاذاعه ومركز
ومركز البحري
ومع استمرار المواجهات بات النزوح هو الحل
امام الالاف من السودانيين هربا من
الاقتتال الدائر في هذه الاثناء ايضا كشفت
بياناته المنظمه الدوليه للهجره الى نزوح
اكثر من
334 الف شخص داخل السودان منذ بدء
الاشتباكات فيما افاد مسؤول بالامم
المتحده بعبور اكثر من 100 الف شخص حدود
السودان الى دول المجاوره حتى الان مؤكدا
ان الامم المتحده بحاجه الى مليار و500
مليون دولار لتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
في السودان لهذا العام
ايضا قرر الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريش ارسال منسق الاغاثه في
حالات الطوارئ ووكيل الامين العام للشؤون
الانسانيه مارتن جرافيت الى السودان
لاستكشاف سبل تقديم الاغاثه الفوريه
لملايين الاشخاص الذين انقلبت حياتهم راسا
على عقب بسبب القتال الدائر في السودان
هذا واظهرت الصور نزوح عشرات الالاف من
الاشخاص عبر نيالا عاصمه جنوب دارفور مع
استمرار المواجهات
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
اتحركنا من يوم الارض من الخرطوم فكان
يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد احنا 28
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم تاشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت
الضرب وطلعنا من يعني طلعنا من الاجوبه
بتاع التوتر والضرب لحد ما حصلنا
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
الجويه قامت باجلاء اكثر من 200 الف شخص
من الاراضي السودانيه على متن اربع طائرات
نقل عسكريه بناء على قرار الرئيس الروسي
بلاد ميرفوتين
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا عطاف محمد مختار
رئيس تحرير صحيفه السوداني مرحبا بك استاذ
عطاف هل هناك معلومات تفصيليه حول الدخان
الذي يتصاعد في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم هناك
بعض المصادر التي تشير الى ان الجيش يقوم
بقصف مواقع عديده للدعم السريع في محيط
المطار والقياده العامه هل من معلومات
تفصيليه
المعلومات التي لدينا تقول ان القوات
الدعم السريع قامت بالمداهمه المطار
خاصه في المطار
النوعيه عمليات فرديه لديهم معلومات انهم
سيقومون بمزيد من التسجيل في
خزانات الوقود الملحقه في المطار كما حدث
في ثاني ايام الحرب التي شلتها الدعم
السريع
حدث قصف خارج المطار لبعض القوات ايضا
هنالك خط حدث في مدينه ام درمان نواحي
المصالحه شوهدت ايضا الطائرات تحلق عاليا
جدا في روبا الخرطوم وايضا شمال الخرطوم
يبدو ان الدعم السريع يحاول نمله اطرافه
مره
اخرى
للمزيد من السيطره كما قلنا في النشرات
السابقه على
قليلا امام بعض المعلومات المهمه التي
تشير اليها السيد عطاف انت تقول ان قوات
الدعم السريع هي من حاولت القيام بهجوم
على المطار وعلى القياده العامه وبالتالي
تعامل الطيران الحربي معها
مع القوات التي خارج المطر مداخل المطار
فهنالك القوات العمليات الخاصه عملاء
الطائر الصاعقه
تم نظرها لهذه العمليات النوعيه المطار
عبر اليات مصفحه مطوره
معلومات الاستثماراتيه التي تقول انه
التفكير من هذا النطاق يعني تفكير في بعض
المناطق العسكريه تفكير في قاعه العسكريه
تفكير بالخزانات الوقود الملحقه بمطار
اسطنبول هذا ما حدث تحدي تقريبا اليوم منذ
الساعه 12 وحتى
وماذا عن الوضع الان
الوضع معقد يعني الوضع المعقد العمليات في
ناس بدات
مع الهويه المدافع
وازاكي
كل يوم يزداد سوءا وكل يوم الناس يعني هذه
الحرب اللعينه وتتمنى انها تتوقف
من الشكاوي والمشاكل يعني اليوم الصحفي
مرضى الكلى الان من عدم توفر الادويه
خصوصا الذين امنوا بزرع هذه الكلة خلال
الشهر الماضي او الشهرين الماضيين او
الذين لديهم جراحات طويله الامد لانهم
يحتاجون للادويه للمضافات في هذه الادويه
ان لم يحضروا عليها
وبالتالي الوفاه تكون يعني
النقطه منذ قليل مع نقابه السودان اطباء
السودان فعلا هناك مشكله تواجه الحالات
الحرجه التي تعاني او اصحاب الامراض
المزمنه ولكن نعود الى الموقف الخاص
بالاشتباكات على الارض الان ما الذي يحدث
والله تقريبا حتى الان هم حسن المعلومات
الوسط الينا حتى الان ايضا مدينه
القوات هنالك وبدا الدخول الى معسكر الذي
تم دفه مره اخرى وبضعه في مناوشات ايضا مع
المواطنين باعداد كبير جدا
وطالم الجيش
وكثيرا في المشاكل التي حدثت من عمليات
النهب
المعلومات السيد عطاف محمد مختار رئيس
تحرير صحيفه السوداني شكرا لك
وينضم الينا من القاهره مع السفير احمد
ابو زيد المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه مرحبا بك معالي السفير هناك جهود
تبذل من جانب مصر ما اخر الاتصالات
الدوليه التي تمت حتى اللحظه مع الاطراف
لمحاوله الوصول الى اتفاق حقيقي لوقف
اطلاق النار
هو في الحقيقه اليوم قرات اتصالات هامه
حيث تلقى السيد سامح شكري وزير الخارجيه
اتصالات من السيد جوزيف بوريل
الممثل الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه والامنيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا تلقى اتصالا اخر
من وزير خارجيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
جميع هذه الاتصالات بتتركز في الوقت
الحالي على كيفيه تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ووضع ضمانات تكفل
الوصول الى هدنه مطوله ومستدامه كي تتمكن
عمليات الاغاثه الانسانيه من الوصول الى
المدنيين وتامين الممرات الامنه
التوصل الى عناصر لوقف اطلاق نار مستدام
وهذا هو الموقف المصري الذي تاسست تاسس
عليه الموقف المصري منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
من خلال المطالبه بالوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار
والوصول الى هدنه تسمح بالتقاط الانفاس
واتاحه الفرصه للحوار بين الاطراف طيب ما
الذي دار في الاتصال الذي تم بين سامح
شكري وانطر بلنكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
هل سمت رؤيا نضجت الان فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الدولي للضغط على الجنراني لوقف حقيقي
لاطلاق النار
هو الحقيقه هناك بالفعل جهود تطلع بها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهناك جهود
تطلع بها مصر مع الشركاء الاقليميين
والدوليين واتصالات تتم على مستوى
الاتحاد الافريقي وجامعه الدول العربيه
واتصالات ثنائيه مع دول جوار السودان مثل
مصر وجنوب السودان وغيرها كل هذه الجهود
بتتركز على فكره التواصل مع جميع الاطراف
مع الطرفين المتنازعين على الارض
لتشجيعهم على اتخاذ القرار الخاص بوقت
اطلاق النار وتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار دون
الخروقات العديده التي تتم حاليا كما
تشاهدي الان هناك
هدنه يتم الوصول اليها ولكن تحدث خروقات
وهذه الخروقات تؤدي الى خروقات من الجانب
الاخر والضحيه الذي يواجه كل هذا الوضع هو
ال ال الشعب السوداني والمواطن السوداني
ومثل عبء كبير بالطبع من خلال
الحدود المشتركه مع السودان واستقبال
المساله النازحين معالي السفير هل تم
التفكير تحديد اليه ما لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار نعلم من بعض المصادر ان كانت هناك
اقتراحات اقليميه وعربيه لتشكيل لجنه يتم
فيها مراقبه وقف اطلاق النار كاجراء يمكن
السيطره به على المشهد هل من اتصالات او
قرارات في هذا الامر يعني هذا الامر مطروح
للحوار في اطار في اوطر عديده الحقيقه في
اطار الاتحاد الافريقي هناك اجتماع يعقد
في الاتحاد الافريقي اليوم بمشاركه مصر
يتم تناول فيه هذه الفكره هناك ايضا
الجامعه العربيه نعلم ان جامعه الدول
العربيه اصدرت قرارا لليوم على مستوى
المندوبين الدائمين وهذا قرار تقدمت به
مصر في الحقيقه صدر اليوم منذ قليل ايضا
مره اخرى بيدعو الى وقف اطلاق النار
ويتناول مسائل عديده من ضمنها اهميه تثبيت
وقف اطلاق النار ويدعو ايضا المجتمع
الدولي لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني ودعم دول السودان التي تتلقى او
تستقبل المواطنين السودانيين عبر الحدود
نعم نعم تم صدور هذا القرار اليوم قرار
هامل الحقيقه لانه يؤكد مره اخرى على دور
الجامعه العربيه ودور الدول العربيه في
التعامل مع هذه الازمه ويؤكد على اهميه
[موسيقى]
ادانه الاستهداف المدنيين والمنشات
المدنيه وضروره الحفاظ ايضا على حرمه
البعثات الدبلوماسيه انت تعلمين ان هناك
احد اعضاء البعثه الدبلوماسيه المصريه
استشهد في في خضم هذه المعارك وكذلك بيؤكد
ايضا على اهميه
السفاره المصريه او القنصليه المصريه في
الخرطوم الان هل قمتم باجلاء فريق
الدبلوماسي
المصري التواجد المصري الدبلوماسي
والقنصلي المصري في السودان متواجد في
مقرات عديده ونعمل على من خلاله على
المساعده في عمليه الاجلاء للمواطنين
المصريين وايضا نساعد رعايه دول اخرى في
عمليات الاجلاء سواء من داخل السودان او
عبر
معلومات تشير معالي السفير وهي تطورات
جديده ان الجيش السوداني وافق بالفعل على
مفاوضات تتم مع قوات الدعم السريع خارج
السودان هل من معلومات حول هذا الامر نعلم
ان جنوب السودان تحاول عقد هذا اللقاء بين
الطرفين عبر ممثلين لهم وهناك دعم مصري
سعودي لهذه المبادره هل من جديد حول هذا
الامر يعني طبعا نحن سمعنا
بالوصول الى الى هدنه مطوله
نحاول ونسعى للتحقق الان من مدى نفاذ هذه
الهدنه والالتزام بها هناك تعلمين ان هناك
مبادره مصريه جنوب سودانيه واتصالات تمت
بين الصليب الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
والرئيس البكير والرئيس الباكيري طلع
باتصالات في هذا الشان مع الطرفين
السودانيين بهدف الوصول الى مثل هذه
الهدنه نعلم ايضا ان الاتحاد الافريقي
والاليه السداسيه والاليه الرباعيه يعملان
ايضا على بهدف الوصول الى هدنه مطوله يعني
ما استطيع ان اقوله هو ان الجميع يتحرك في
نفس الاتجاه الدول
المباشر
بالجنرلين البرهان وحمي مصر تجري اتصالات
مباشره بالطرفين مصر اكدت منذ اليوم الاول
انها على قنوات الاتصال المصريه مع جميع
الاطراف السودانيه مفتوحه دائما والرساله
المصريه للطرفين دائما هي ضروره الوصول
الى وقف فوري الاطلاق النار طيب
رئيس السودانيين وان هذا يشكل تحديا كبيرا
بالنسبه لمصر على الاقل ايضا من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه هل تمت اتصالات بين مصر وبين
الامم المتحده بين منظمات دوليه لمحاوله
الدعم في هذا الوضع
اولا كما اشرت القرار الصادر عن جامعه
الدول العربيه اليوم بيطالب الدول المانحه
والمنظمات الدوليه المعنيه بتقديم الدعم
لدول جوار السودان التي تستقبل الوافدين
من السودانيين عبر الحدود فهذا مطلب عربي
تم التعبير عنه رسميا اليوم ايضا هذا
الموضوع محل كان محل حوارا حوار
بين السيد وزير الخارجيه مع الممثل الاعلى
للاتحاد الاوروبي للشؤون السياسيه
الخارجيه مع وزير خارجيه الولايات المتحده
هناك في الواقع تقدير نراه ملحوظا من جانب
المؤسسات الدوليه ومن جانب منظمات الامم
المتحده والشركاء في الدول المانحه للدور
الذي تطلع به مصر في هذا الامر واستعداد
دائم لتقديم الدعم لمصر خلال المرحله
القادمه لمساعدتها في هذا المجال ايضا
معالي السفير بالتاكيد الكل يتطلع الى
وقفه حقيقيه لاطلاق النار تتم بعده وفقا
لتصريحات صحفيه لحضرتك البدء في مساله
الحوار والتفاوض هل تم التطرق الى مساله
مستقبل هذا الحوار خلال لقاء المبعوث
البرهان اليوم مع وزير خارجيه المصري ام
ان الجهود تتركز فقط على الهدف الاهم الان
وهو وقف اطلاق النار
الهدف الان الاساسي هو
احترام وقف اطلاق النار احترام الطرفين
لوقت اطلاق النار الوصول الى هدنه مطوله
ومستدامه كما اشرت تسمح بالتقاط الامثال
ونفاذ المساعدات الانسانيه وعمليات
الاغاثه هذا هو التركيز حاليا هذا الامر
يمكن ان يتطور في مرحله لاحقه لحوار اكثر
تفصيلا حول قضايا اخرى ولكن تركيز جهود
المجتمع الدولي حاليا تنصبب الاساس على
انفاذ وقف اطلاق النار واحترامه ووضع
ضمانات تكفل عدم خرق هذه الهدنه في اي
مرحله من
نعم السفير احمد ابو زيد المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه المصريه شكرا لك على هذه
المداخله وكما استمعنا كان هناك اتصال تم
بين وزير خارجيه المصريه سامح شكري وانطني
بلانكين وزير خارجيه الامريكي وكان ايضا
هناك استقبال لمبعوث البرهان في القاهره
اليوم للدفع بعمليه وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات